when we March down the street we say
free free Palestine look what's going on
right here in the United States this is
a pramas rally pramas this is not for
the people of Gaza if you want them to
live free this is a pramas rally in
Rashida talib's district in dearb
Michigan and this is chilling this is
chilling this is Nazi 1938 level stuff
so don't let them get it twisted this is
not complicated when you go to a black
lives matter rally you see Palestinian
flag when you go to a white supremacy
rally you see Israeli Flags this is not
complicated when zionists March down the
street they say death to Arabs when we
March down the street we say free free
Palestine free free Palestine this is
not difficult
everybody what do you think those people
would do to their their neighbors not
I'm guessing not many Jews in dear boor
Michigan but what do you think those
people would do when you when you hear
that there is a a call or a day of rage
tomorrow like who are they talking to
when they say do it all over the
world I don't know also everything he
said there was complete nonsense uh
White supremist rallies that have
Israeli Flags first of I don't know of
any white supremacist rallies that have
happened in the United States like
within the last 30 years or so there's
probably a couple white supremacist
somewhere not great people there you go
we did it okay easy enough they carry
Israeli Flags oh and that the zionists
are chanting death to the Arabs no one's
chanting death to the Arabs and no one
ever does having been to Israel many
times all these people ever talk about
is peace the country is constantly at
war with itself over how to get peace
right like do we leave give them land
for peace do we not should we uh you
know have uh Commerce with them or not
like what do we they they just did it
again they shot more Rockets into us
should we have more peace like
everything they have done is in the name
of Peace everything they have done uh as
many people point out if the uh if the
Palestinians laid down their arms there
would be peace tomorrow if the Israelis
laid down their arms there would be a
mass genocide that is just so obvious
and everyone knows it imagine if the
power situation was reversed right here
what would be going on you all know it
everyone knows it um and also this you
know so the the zionists shout shout
kill the Arabs or whatever and we shout
free free
yeah that that is a call for genocide
right River to the Sea uh yeah that
means uh no Jews living there so there
you go um I don't know what you have to
do with these people we we are going to
be in a massive fight over free speech
in this country because at what point
you you can have whatever odious views
you want and you can get as close to
that line there's no such thing as hate
speech right I have defended hate speech
many times don't forget the ACLU
defended the rights of neo-nazis to
march in skoki Illinois in 197 2 SK
Illinois had I think the largest
contingent of Holocaust survivors in the
United States we always want to defend
all of our ideals but at what point when
a group of people in our own country are
defending a terrorist organization that
is literally calling for people to kill
people in our country at what point do
we have to have a different conversation
and again I would link this to what I
started with the show what I started the
show with we have so obliterated our
sense making Hamas basically has a
television channel on MSNBC we have so
few people who can analyze anything
honestly that it leaves us confused and
it leaves us basically unable to see
evil and know what to do about
it